I wasn't sure I could make this
collector mania and I was doing post
production on my new film that I shot
here this summer the last showing
starring kim jones from the game of
thrones and the beautiful Emily
Barrington from White Queen and I play
the old projectionists who's been made
redundant and has his revenge at the
midnight movie so I was able to see the
trailer for it down in London this week
and it's just it looks great i'm so
happy this this kid is phil hawkins this
director he's so talented and I'm so
happy to be part of their team now so
and I was able to run up to milton
keynes you know for the con well tell us
a bit more about the film what can we
expect to see in it and when can we
expect to see it when it comes out in
2014 and i guess the best way to
classify it would be to call it a
thriller but what I love about the film
is that the old projectionists me in us
and I'm sort of you know borrowing a bit
from Richard Attenborough and seance on
a wet afternoon and and and some other
things but they use all this different
point of view media's in it
closed-circuit television I I manipulate
that and I exploit that then I actually
you know have my own little camera that
i use and then my cell phone camera and
a laptop camera
and using all of those sources I pick an
anonymous couple at a midnight screening
at a last showing and I make a movie
using them which is also my revenge on
the boss that made me redundant that
fired main punish me and sent me
downstairs shoveling popcorn until my
retirement kicks in so it's real
interesting it was really fun to do it
it's it's psychological but again you
have all of these different point of
views all the different cameras that are
that I use to manipulate this beautiful
young couple finn jones and emily
barrington as i take advantage of them
now we've interviewed fit quite a few
times about gamers residents if he's
dead what was it like working with those
guys well Finn is terrific you know I
mean I I see him as kind of cross
between the late Heath Ledger and
orlando bloom but you know Finn's big
he's a big guy he's tall and so he has
that extra gift of strength even when
he's very quiet on camera but you know
when you see Finn just walking around
when he's not acting he's like a big
skateboarder you know he looks like a
big skater you know but it but we had a
really rough night the two of us where
we had to sell this sequence in the
bowels of the multiplex we are fighting
at a doorway to the projection room and
we it's a real door it's not a movie set
and it had weight to it and you know we
both want to look ballsy you know and
strong and macho even though I was sort
of playing this this lonely little man
and we're you know but I at this point
in the film I I have to be able to keep
him from getting in this this room and
it was all night with this door and and
both of us are using muscles you don't
normally use because we're trying to
he's trying to open it i'm trying to
close it he's trying to open it I'm
trying to close it and it was so funny
because the next day I could barely get
out of bed you know it's like thin would
you quit being such a method actor it up
now am i right in thinking he filmed in
the North West of England well I we film
nights and and we thought we were so
smart and clever because we filmed from
midnight until noon you know because we
had to use the movie theater but they
had that hit movie Despicable Me 2 and
in in the UK you guys do the early
matinee now for the kids on holiday so
here I am walking around the lobby you
know with emily and fin we've got blood
all over us and it's like nine ten in
the morning and the kids are already
lined up you know and all the little
girls are there my little pony dolls you
know and all the little boys and they
all want to go up and pet the giant
despicable me 2 minion you know and then
here comes Robert Englund trudging
through the lobby at ten in the morning
with all these beautiful little English
school girls and their backpacks and
their My Little Ponies and they're
lovely Gwyneth Paltrow Sloane Ranger
mums and Here I am you know with blood
all over me I was like kind of I don't
know it was kind of tragic but he slowed
us down a bit you know so so we were
kind of up against the wall and and I
was you know Chester this the town I was
staying it has such a lovely racetrack
and I wanted to go to the races one day
you know and just have a couple of
serious summer drinks you know I'm
trying to think you know neither either
a nice Tanqueray on ice or a you know a
Pimm's Cup or two you know and watch the
races but I was so exhausted I never
came out of the hotel until night I was
like a vampire the vampire of gesture I
think one night I found a wonderful
little club that had a great DJ and he
was mixing b-sides of Stevie Wonder and
that was sort of my one night out you
know
I can't wait till the film it sounds
absolutely great well I'm telling you
this company they're all young and I
would crawl on my hands and knees to
work with them again you just get this
sense when you're my age and an occasion
I get thrown in with these young kids
that are so terrifically a
state-of-the-art and imaginative and fun
and this this this English crew this
film company and its spelled it's a pun
because Phil Hawkins uses the ph IL of
his name for film you know and they're
just a terrific young group I think
they're working on a new project now
called baptism they're very clever I
think they went out an option some
European bestseller before it got
translated into English you know they're
really shrewd these these kids and I'm
really happy to be part of their new
team look forward to seeing it of course
can't have you here without talking to
you a little bit about like parallel
Street I've got to ask about it I mean
obviously such an iconic character such
an iconic set of movies I mean what is
it about Freddy and the nightmare series
that still resonates with people do you
think well I mean it's all Wes and I'm
so surprised that no one came up with
this hook before you know Hollywood has
always had a love affair with a dream
sequence you know you can see it in all
the old MGM musicals and even some film
noir from the late 40s but the idea of
the dream sequence the dream landscape
the landscape of the imagination and the
subconscious being this place where you
could be haunted by a serial killer by a
boogeyman Freddy Krueger is such a great
hook and it's it's universal all
cultures you know suffer the nightmare
as as a common denominator in in every
race and culture so we instantly became
this sort of international success and
also horror movies much like sci-fi and
fantasy and even action movies they
speak the international language of
cinema and film whereas romantic comedy
comedy doesn't always translate from
culture to culture I don't think I could
name a single Spanish comedian if I had
to I love Pedro Almodovar I love Spanish
horror but they don't know our comics we
don't know there's but I'm sure they
know I know they know Freddy Krueger and
i know i know some of the great vampire
movies that were made in spain in the
70s so that's that world that translates
you know I mean I loved guillermo del
toro's film The Devil's Backbone which
was made in Spain you know a ghost story
set against the set against the
aftermath of the Spanish Civil War
terrific terrific film so so that those
will be translate they go back and forth
culturally and I think that's the great
happy accident of my career is that I
had the sort of one-two punch of the
sci-fi series v and then the nightmare
on elm street franchise which again this
international language of cinema so I'm
able to do movies i think i've done like
maybe a dozen maybe more movies on the
continent now you had that success as
well basically back-to-back didn't do
you mean it has been incredible for you
well it was you know two years of V and
then ten years of Nightmare on Elm
Street you know and then a 10 year break
and then a Freddy vs. Jason which is I
think this is the tenth reunion of
Freddy vs. Jason and next year will be
the 30th anniversary of the original
nightmare on elm street and this year is
my 40th year in movies yeah what was it
like going back after that gap well in
the 10 years i did some family films and
i did some i did a television series and
i did a lot of movies in europe and the
US i did a couple of comedies it was
when I did Freddy vs. Jason I was
worried because I had a lot of stunts in
that now I could do the water stunts
because I'm an old surfer but what got
me through it was my mate Ken cursing
her who is a big stunt coordinator from
Vancouver who's worked on just about
every movie made
ken wit played Jason and I felt in
really good hands with him because he is
a stuntman and stunt coordinator and in
fact the only the only thing that ever
happened dangerous on this set of Freddy
vs. Jason was Ken was standing with his
back against a wall on fire one day
doing his really cool Jason walked
towards me very slowly and he started to
smoke his costume he had a lot of hair
on the Jason cloak the Jason jacket and
there was a lot of strings on its
stringing shredded stuff on that and it
started to smoke so he that was actually
a greater danger than I ever was on the
on the movie do you ever feel that you'd
kind of like to turn up at a Halloween
party in Freddy's because do you well
you know I just did a couple of personal
appearances for the holiday season the
Halloween holiday in the states and the
new thing is not so much guys as Freddy
but the girls they all wear that sweater
is a miniskirt and then they wear these
big clunky work boots with really sexy
opera hose and I Ilan's you know fishnet
stockings and they're all kind of
strategically slashed you know a little
bit of cleavage here a little bit of
tummy there a little bit of piercing
there here and there and they wear the
half the fedora you know and it's sort
of like these sexy Freddy yets they look
like if I had backup singers in
purgatory or something you know i mean
could you ever to envisage that
happening when you started I was pretty
those years ago no you know I was so
preoccupied by my success and my first
taste of celebrity with v people knew my
face but no one had ever known my name
before but people are putting my name
too you know that my name to my face and
I just thought I was doing this little
horror movie you know with his talented
guy Wes Craven who we sort of thought of
as a kind of David Lynch Lynch character
back then
and the next thing i know they canceled
v because it was so expensive and i had
gone to New York to sign autographs with
William Shatner at a science fiction
convention because my character had sort
of was the breakaway character and the
kind of logo character on v along with
jane badler as Diana and I was signing
autographs and my line changed from
sci-fi fans into heavy metal punk rock
leather-clad Freddy fans and that was my
first inkling that it had a life of its
own and we don't there was only one
release print I think on the east coast
at that time and I really knew when I
saw like three hundred fans standing in
the rain in downtown New York Manhattan
that Freddie had had legs as we say in
show business I mean invention 70s
Spanish horror films ago I have much
more horror fan are you yourself and
what do you think about the state of
horror movies today well I I love horror
films and I love science fiction and
fantasy and as a child I was a huge fan
but I was quite a snob in the 60s and
70s I was a big fan of the English new
wave I wanted to be Albert Finney I
wanted to be Alan Bates I wanted to be
Tom Courtenay I wanted to be Peter
O'Toole and you know I sort of outgrown
my Marlon Brando James Dean phase and I
was in love with those guys and I I
forget I think West taught me to respect
the genre again and about six or seven
years ago I had this memory repressed
memory come back I remember going to my
Godfather's home in
in the valley when I was a child at the
cocktail parties I would go into his
office and look at the coffee table
books from Simon & Schuster and there
was one that was life's history of met
of Hollywood and there's a whole section
on horror and a whole section on the
Golden Age of [ __ ] in the 1930s as well
as I remember this fold-out page of lon
chaney the man of a thousand faces and
all of these sort of postage stamp-sized
photos of all the various makeups he'd
done there was even one where he'd hard
boiled an egg and taken off the
placentia and put it over his eyes to
play a blind person with that milky
covering that you see on a hard-boiled
egg and I was so entranced by that then
every time I would go to see my
godparents I would look at that mag I
got that coffee table book and those
photos and I'm wondering if that wasn't
some latent thing that I'd kind of
buried through my kind of turtleneck and
corduroy jacket period of being a
Shakespearean actor and all that and
that when i was offered Freddie I'm
wondering that the challenge of makeup
wasn't some leftover desire that I had
is a little eight-year-old Robbie
England looking at that book and all
those pictures of the man with a
thousand faces and you know maybe that
was that childhood sense of wonder you
know was the reason I I said yes to
Freddie and and it turned out quite well
finally what kind of horror gets you
excited now well you know I just saw the
conjuring and I love lili taylor and i
love vera farmiga but I one of my
favorite I I go back and I can remember
the 1974 film Brian De Palma's sisters
which was a film I really think is
underrated and I really love that film
you know Margot Kidder is brilliant in
it and one of my favorite mad scientists
William Finley some of the best use of
split-screen and there's a great
nightmare sequence a drugged nightmare
sequence in that movie that that takes
the form stylistically of the old
microfiche that you would see in
libraries which I just think is a
brilliant cons
so that's one of my favorite horror
films but you know I'm yeah I'm very
open in my tastes I like everything you
know I recently like dark skies I think
is it was a very interesting little film
I mean original in its own way but I
think it really worked on me it really
gave me I liked it was kind of dark and
disturbing do you like say to your fans
here watching this video at that well I
just want to tell all my fans that I i
start fear clinic and a lot of fans out
there that worked on our campaign and
everything and we finally got to make it
work i'm off to star with the wonderful
young actor thomas dekker from
terminator sarah connor chronicles and
the this new young actress that I love
who's the daughter of one of my favorite
actors Brad Dourif Fiona door from the
curse of Chucky and she's my leading
ladies so to speak and I'm really
excited about it Robert Hall who's been
working on everything since Buffy the
Vampire Killer through Teen Wolf and
we're off to Cleveland for the holidays
to make it and next year coming to a
theater or a driving or a DVD outlet
near you or a download from netflix
check out the last showing in the UK
starring finn jones and emily barrington
and myself maybe in the States it's
going to be called a midnight movie but
these are my next to ventures so check
them out we look for saying there's
loads of lovely new filming as well we
look forward to seeing what happens with
that thank you
you